serena williams gives birth the 35 year
old tennis champ has welcomed her first
child with fiance alexis ohanian
I'm excited about it the proud parents
waited until giving birth to find out
the gender of their baby in July Serena
took to Instagram writing so few
surprises in life these days that's why
I'm waiting to find out the sex of the
baby the tennis legend nearly broke the
internet when she accidentally announced
that she was expecting back in April
since then she's delighted Instagram
followers with a number of gorgeous
pregnancy pics and it seems Serena and
her 34 year old reddit co-founder fiance
have been busy preparing to welcome
their little one in July the famous
athlete took to snapchat giving us a
glimpse of baby class where the duo
practiced their swaddling skills they
opened up about the pregnancy and their
love story in the August issue of Vanity
Fair serena revealing she took six
pregnancy tests in the week leading up
to her domination at the australian open
[Music]
you